hi in this video I'm going to describe
the mechanism of action of p53 and p53
is actually a tumor suppressor protein
and it's also a help in cell cycle
regulation and also acts are important
clear in the acts as an important player
in the cell cycle checkpoint so you try
to discuss one checkpoint and try to
elaborate the function of p53 and how it
functions as a key player of the DNA
damage checkpoint so here we have a cell
our healthy cell so inside the cell we
have the nucleus and so here we have our
DNA inside the nucleus and and due to
some reason there is a ionizing
radiation and this ionizing radiation
causes or damage in these DNA and as a
result there is a double strand DNA
break which is actually very common DNA
lesion and now we would see what happens
and how cell behaves when there is such
kind of DNA lesions so if we just zoom
into this portion so we would see that
there is a DNA lesion double strand DNA
break in this situation if cell allows
it to divide then it would be quite
dangerous cause in the daughter cell
these there would be a uneven
segregation of the genetic material so
unequal distribution of the genetic
material so that is not expected so that
is why cell have to devise our mechanism
by which it can actually tell the cell
to repair this kind of damage at least
try to repair this kind of damage
and so this is actually regulated by p53
so before knowing p53 so we have to
understand that there are some factors
which actually helps in the recognition
of these a lesion DNA lesion so such as
us for instance say this is our UV ray
you will actually damage the DNA so
there must be some sensors which
actually sends this kind of damage so
one type of sensor is ATR or another
type is ATM so ATM stands for ataxia
telangiectasia mutated in East so
whatever we should think it as a sensor
it would sense that there is a double
strand DNA break and it would tell its
friend which is actually a kinase called
check one kinase and this check one
kinase would perform a particular
function so this chick one kinase would
phosphorylate or downstream protein and
let's see what is that particular
downstream protein so in the meanwhile
in the cell what we have in p53 is
actually inhibited by another protein
named as mdm2 so mdm2 is actually
inhibiting p53 but p53 gets
phosphorylated by chick 1 when they when
ATM senses our ATM or eighty our senses
our DNA damage so then p53 is actually
phosphorylated
so then mdm2 can't hold p53 any longer
now p53 is now free and p53 has multiple
transcription targets so one of the
transcription target of p53 is p21
so as I have discussed earlier in my
videos that p21 is actually a inhibitor
of s-phase cycling's so extra cycling's
are like if we named them then it is
cycling it is cycling II and cdk2
so what happens that these p21 actually
inhibits these cycling II and cdk2 and
cycling e cdk2 can't perform its
function it can perform its function
as a result what happens so as a result
of these inhibition of cycling II and
cdk2 what would happen cell cycle
progression stops and now cell would get
some time to actually divide as the cell
would get actually some time to think
and to try to repair the DN and if the
DNA is repaired successfully then cell
would resume its division if the repair
is not successful or the damage what is
caused by these UV radiation or any kind
of radiation is a very harsh and a very
serious and it is irreparable then what
happens the cell would undergo
programmed cell death also known as
apoptosis so in this way p53 along with
p21 which is a cyclin dependent kinase
inhibitor helps to regulate the cell
cycle when there is a DNA damage and
this is the basic molecular mechanism of
DNA damage checkpoints hope you enjoyed
the video please like and subscribe
thank you